I mean it's kind of funny going for a
Big Bang Theory it said that cup I mean
you get to like it's a completely
different role playing Harlequin how is
it well it's like a badass within like
therapy for me
because I spend two hours in a booth by
myself screaming and cussing I want this
job it's early and say the show's
hilarious but I'm not trying to bias it
is the scripts and the writing is genius
but it's a lot of screaming and just
it's psychotic I've never spoken like
this before
me me neither yeah me no no my frown
upon fouling yes that was that what yeah
I'm sure
there was at one point we got some notes
i'm bobby was from it might have been
from the networkers sir I'm not sure but
it was like it's just too many F words
probably the network yeah yeah and we
got this thing like you've got to cut it
back like it was like one after but I
mean it was so it's a great herb
sometime I see it almost kicks it out
it's a great verse I love that went into
it I mean my mom hates it by the way so
does my god
they let us say my parent if I'll say a
word it's like they can't stand when I
cut my mother same thing with my music
career and then I get to this and she's
like you're having a talk show okay
you've got to close your mouth so
southern mom I'm sorry nice Hilarion get
the beauty-queen perfect I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this